[Music]
the talented young herbalist named Shu
Chien was in trouble it should have been
a victorious moment he had just opened
his very own medicine shop but he bought
his supplies from his former employer
and the resentful man sold him rotten
herbs as she soon wondered what to do
with this useless inventory patients
flooded into his shop a play catch
tricking the city and he had nothing to
treat them just as he was starting to
panic his wife by sujin produced a
recipe to use the rotten herbs as
medicine her remedy cured all the plague
afflicted citizens immediately she shins
former boss even had to buy back some of
the rotten herbs to treat his own family
shortly after a monk named fahai
approached Shushan warning him that
there was a demon in his house the demon
he said was by sujin shoot n laughed his
kind-hearted resourceful wife was not a
demon fahai insisted he told she seemed
to serve his wife reales our wine on the
fifth day of the fifth month when demons
powers are weakest if she wasn't a demon
he explained it wouldn't hurt her she's
in dismissed the monk politely with no
intention of serving by su gender-wise
but as the day approached he decided to
try it as soon as the wine touched by
soo Jin's lips she ran to the bedroom
claiming she wasn't feeling well
she Sam prepared some medicine and went
to check on her but instead of his wife
he found a giant white serpent with a
bloody forked tongue in the bed he
collapsed killed by the shock when by
sewage and opened her eyes she realized
immediately what must have happened the
truth was that Biogen was an immortal
snake with formidable magical powers she
had used her powers to take a human form
and improve her and her husband's
fortunes her magic couldn't revive
but she had one more idea to save him an
herb that could grant longevity and even
bring the dead back to life guarded by
the old man of the South Pole in the
forbidden peaks of the Quinlin mountains
she rode to the mountains on a cloud
then continued on foot pass gateways and
arches until she reached white marks
beyond mortals hanging over a silver
bridge on the other side two of the old
man's disciples guarded the earth by a
surgeon disguised herself as a month and
told them she'd come to invite the old
man to a gathering of the gods
while they relayed her message she
plucked some leaves from the herb and
ran the servants realized they had been
tricked and chased her by a Shogun
coughed up a magic ball and threw it at
one as the other closed in on her she
put the herb under her tongue for
safekeeping
but it's magic forced both of them into
their true forms as the crayons long
beak clamped around her the old man
appeared why he asked which she risked
her life to steal his herb when she was
already immortal by certain explained
her love for Shion even if he didn't
want to be with her now that he knew she
was a demon she was determined to bring
him back to life the two had a karmic
connection dating back more than a
thousand years when Biogen was a small
snake a beggar was about to kill her but
a kind passerby rescued her her rescuer
was GCN past life touched by her
willingness to risk her life for him the
old man permitted her to leave the
mountain with the immortal earth by
Hudson returned home to revive she's yet
when he opened his eyes the terrified
look frozen on his face became a smile
demon or not he was still happy to see
his wife if you were facing a God's
wrath and punishment would you rather be
turned into a spider or have everything
you touch turn to gold choose your fate
with one of these lessons
[Music]